vamos a resolver esta pregunta dice que
susana está en una expedición para
salvar al universo en su reto final ella
tiene que jugar un juego llamado
encuentra los rombos un mago le dice que
él tiene un cuadrado un cuadrilátero y
un paralelogramo y ella tiene que
identificar cuáles de esas figuras
también son rombos entonces la pregunta
es cuáles de las figuras cuál o cuáles
de las figuras deberá elegir para salvar
al universo bueno pues el mago tiene un
cuadrado un cuadrado es un cuadrilátero
que tiene sus cuatro lados iguales y sus
cuatro ángulos de 90 grados y un rombo
es un cuadrilátero que tiene sus cuatro
lados iguales entonces en efecto un
cuadrado es un rombo esa es una de las
respuestas correctas la siguiente dice
un cuadrilátero un cuadrilátero pues es
muy general verdad un cuadrilátero
simplemente es una figura con cuatro
lados pero para que sea rombo los cuatro
lados deben ser iguales entonces este de
aquí no no necesariamente es un rombo
así que es bueno no elegirlo para salvar
al universo y finalmente un
paralelogramo
un paralelogramo pues no necesariamente
el rombo simplemente tiene pares de
lados opuestos casi paralelos pero pero
eso no quiere decir que sean iguales es
decir no cumple la definición de rombo
no necesariamente entonces el cuadrado
es la única de las opciones correctas
muy bien vamos a hacer otro dice freddy
decide tratar de confundir a sus amigos
él les dice que tiene una galleta
especial que es tanto un rectángulo como
un rombo si le pueden decir qué figura
es el compartirá la galleta con ellos y
la pregunta es cuál es el nombre más
preciso para la figura de la galleta de
freddy bueno pues como es un rectángulo
es un cuadrilátero con sus cuatro
ángulos de 90 grados y como es un rombo
los cuatro lados tienen la misma
longitud y la única figura que tiene
cuatro lados iguales y cuatro ángulos de
la misma longitud es el cuadrado vale
entonces aquí la respuesta sería
cuadrado vamos a ver qué pasa muy bien